In early March, West Virginia's teachers
ended a nine-day strike after the
legislature adopted a 5% boost in
teacher pay. Missing from the headlines
was much attention to how West Virginia
got here:
West Virginia added staff while losing
students. Over more than two decades, West
Virginia student enrollment fell by 12%,
but non-teaching staff grew by 10%! In
fact, between 1992 and 2014, real per-pupil spending rose 39%, but real teacher
pay actually fell three percent! Consider
this: A West Virginia teacher would today
earn more than $63,000 a
year if teacher pay had simply kept pace
with per-pupil spending. Salaries are
only part of the story, of course. West
Virginia ranks in the top five
nationally in terms of retirement costs.
That comes at the expense of take-home
pay. Look, take home pay for West
Virginia's teachers is pretty dismal, and
this 5% bump certainly helps. But this
settlement is a costly patch that didn't
address a frustrating status quo.
What do you think should be done about teacher pay? Let us know in your comments. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.